even the white house cannot explain its
reasoning anymore on its virus and
vaccine policy i'm not sure the white
house ever could really explain it all
that well but but they would have
certain lines that would within their
own narrow context be at least
semi-coherent you need to get vaccinated
to protect the people from you you need
the vaccines are extremely effective
whatever you know at the time these
things seemed sort of plausible
now they don't
peter ducey
one of the few reporters who asks
difficult questions at the white house
peter ducey came out and asked press
secretary jensaki hey jen
since
i'm faxed and i got kovid and you're
vaxxed and you got kovid how come joe
biden is still calling this a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
i understand that the science says that
vaccines prevent death
but
i'm triple vaxxed still got coveted your
triple backs still got cobit
why is the president still referring to
this as a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
well i i think peter there's a
significant difference between and you
just you just experienced this and not
to expose your public health experience
but i can speak to mo mine as well
i had been triple vaxxed i had minor
symptoms there is a huge difference
between that and being unvaccinated you
are 17 times more likely to go to the
hospital if you're not vaccinated 20
times more likely to die and those are
significant serious statistics so yes
the impact
for people who are unvaccinated is far
more dire than those who are vaccinated
will the president update his language
at some time to be more reflective of
the fact that people who are triple
vaccinated are catching and spreading
colvin i think people president has said
as have we a number of times that there
will be breakthrough cases there will be
people who get covid uh here
at different media organizations at
companies around the world around the
country who have been vaccinated
how many millions of break breakthrough
cases do we need to have before we can
stop calling them breakthrough cases how
many do you think on january 17th tens
of thousands of men are going to start
living a different life that different
life is going to help them turn away
from eating too much drinking too much
and spending too much time in the office
it's going to challenge them to stop
ignoring their wives children or friends
by putting a pause on their social media
turning off netflix youtube and sports
men if you desire freedom true freedom
from attachments freedom to be a better
husband a better father and a better man
for others i invite you to check out
exodus 90.com
michael starting january 17th exodus 90
will take men on a 90-day journey
through the book of exodus taking them
back to the fundamentals of the faith
prayer self-denial and brotherhood tens
of thousands of men from all around the
world will start exodus 90 this year on
january 17th 2022 to journey through
lend and end on easter sunday to date
more than 50 000 men have done exodus 90
99 reported experiencing greater freedom
i invite you to join them on this
life-changing journey head on over to
exodus 90.com michael to sign up set
your start date for january 17th and
invite a few friends to journey with you
that is exodus
slash michael i'm i'm thinking right now
just off the top of my head of all my
friends and family members who have
gotten coveted some are vaccinated some
are vaccinated and boosted uh some are
not vaccinated at all and won't go near
the fauciachi
i guess the majority of my friends and
family who have gotten it
have been vaccinated
and some people had serious symptoms or
relatively you know by serious i mean
they were in bed for a couple days and
some people
really had very mild symptoms and there
was really no rhyme or reason
as to who had
which sort of severity of symptoms
between the unvaccinated the vaccinated
and the boosted
but furthermore speaking of symptoms do
you think jen saki threw her back out
moving the goal posts like that
i hope she didn't i hope she's feeling
better but that must have been very
strenuous because peter ducey asked a
very simple question
since
people who have been vaccinated and
boosted
are contracting and spreading
coronavirus
when is the president going to stop
calling it a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
and what did she say she said
well it's much worse for people who have
who are unvaccinated
but that's not the question
we're talking about the pandemic we're
talking about people who are contracting
and spreading a virus and the and the
virus is
mutating and it's contagious and it's
spreading throughout the country and
that's happening happening with
vaccinated people as well as
unvaccinated people
so why is joe biden lying and saying
that it's only happening with
unvaccinated people
she says well sure there are some
breakthrough cases no that's not what's
going on there just everyone's getting
it lady everyone's getting this thing
well it's because omicron is is
different yeah okay yeah it's a variant
viruses have variants as they always do
and always will and always we're going
to
so why are you still pretending
that this is a virus that's only being
contracted and spread by people who are
unvaccinated well it's a lot worse if
you're okay so they have nothing so they
have absolutely nothing and they're
deflecting
hey i'll make this quick ring the bell
please that would be great ring the bell
subscribe get those notifications
really if you want the notifications
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five-star review see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]